من جديد الى وليد العمري مدير مكتبنا في
رام الله لنتوقف اكثر عند تصريحات نتنياهو
واضح جدا وليد ان اسرائيل ماضيه باستهداف
شخصيات بعينها في الداخل اللبناني تتحدى
حزب الله ونتنياهو يقول سنفعل كل ما يلزم
لاعاده الامن الى الحدود مع
لبنان حتى الساعه ليس هناك اي تطرق رسمي
اسرائيلي الى قضيه اغتيال وسام الطويل
قيادي الميدان الكبير في قوات النخبه
الرضوان التابعه لحزب الله لكن السرعه
التي تناقلت فيها وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه النباه وذهبت جميعها الى نسبه
الى الى مصادر لبنانيه لحظه وقوعه
بالاضافه الى ان نتنياهو كان يتواجد في
كريات ش مونا في الجليل الاعلى وادلى بهذه
التصريحات توضح من يقف وراء مثل هذا
الاغتيال نتنياهو في تصريحه ذهب الى القول
ان حزب الله ان حزب الله يتحدث عن ان
اسرائيل هي بيت العنكبوت ونحن نريه الان
ما اي بيت عنكبوت هذا واضاف بان اسرائيل
تريد ان تحقق الامن واعادته الى كافه
المناطق الشماليه المتاخمه للحدود مع
لبنان دون ان تخوض حرب واسعه لكنها لن
تتوقف وستواصل بمعنى ان ذلك لن يردعها هذه
التصريحات لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي ومن
موقعها في منطقه كريات ش مونا تحديدا التي
قال انه جاء اليها بعد ان تعرضت للقصف
اليوم متضامنا وايضا للتاكيد الدعم تشير
الى ان سياسه اسرائيل متواصله على عده
مستويات هي من ناحيه وضعت قواتها ومنذ
بدايه الحرب على غزه قبل 994 يوما وضعتها
على في اقصى حالات التاهب وعلى اهبه
الاستعداد للتعامل مع كافه الاحتمالات
ثانيا التصعيد الذي نحن في هو متواصل بشكل
واضح منذ ان قامت اسرائيل باغتيال الشيخ
صالح العاروري في الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت
وايضا بعد ان كان حزب الله قد قصف موقعا
عسكريا استراتيجيا اسرائيليا على قمه جبل
الجرمق
ميرون وحضر الجيش الاسرائيلي نشر معلومات
حتى صباح هذا اليوم ليعترف بانه كانت هناك
اصابات محققه لكنه ادعى بانها لم تعطل عمل
هذه المحطه الهامه التي تقوم برصد
التحركات في منطقه الهلال ال خصيب وتركيا
ايضا وهي ربما المره الاولى التي يتعرض
بها هذا الموقع المحصن والمحمي جيدا لمثل
هذا القصف واعتبر ذلك انه جاء ردا على
اغتيال العاروري في بيروت يضاف الى هذا
كله عمليات قصف والقصف المتبادل التي
تتواصل على طول الحدود مع لبنان يوميا وهو
وقصف سواء من داخل لبنان باتجاه المناطق
الجليلي الاسرائيليه في الشمال او الرد
الاسرائيلي والقصف المكثف بالطائرات
والمدفعيه والذي تعمق خلال الايام الاخرى
الاخيره ليصل الى عمق لبنان ولم يعد فقط
في الشريط الحدودي مثل ما كان في الايام
او الاشهر الاولى الشهرين الاولين للحرب
على قطاع غزه من هنا واضح بان اسرائيل
تحاول ان تبعث برساله واضحه ل حزب الله
وايضا للمفاوضين والوسطاء الذين ينشطون في
المنطقه بانها متاهب للقيام ولقيام
بعمليات عسكريه واسعه اذا اقتضت الضروره
وعمليه الاغتيال الاخيره سواء اعلنت
اسرائيل مسؤوليتها عنها ام لم تعلن واضح
بانها تصب في هذا السياق وانه الان هم
بانتظار ان يكون هناك ردا من حزب الله
عليها ربما بنفس المستوى لان الرد الذي
كان يوم السبت مساء وتحديدا استهداف
القاعده العسكريه الهامه على جبل ميرون
الجرمق شكل في نظر اسرائيل انه بدايه رد
على اغتيال العاروري لكنه ايضا تجاوز ل
قواعد الاشتباك مع حزب الله الذي استخدم
تكتيكا
كان اوهم الاسرائيليين واظهر بان لدى حزب
الله ايضا خيارات لالام اسرائيل حيث قام
بالبدايه بعمليات قصف بالصواريخ والقذائف
في المناطق المحيطه واستخدمت اسرائيل
القبه الحديديه بعدها فورا تم اطلاق 62
صاروخا حديثا على هذا الموقع والمواقع
المحيطه واصيب الموقع وان كان الجيش يقول
بانه لم يتعطل الموقف على طول الحدود مع
لبنان حاليا بانتظار ما سيكون عليه الرد
من جانب حزب الله بعد اغتيالي الطويل وا
تصريحات نتنياهو واضحه وتوحي بان اسرا انه
ربما كان على علم بذلك او علم بلحظتها
ووزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي جلنت هو الاخر
سيقدم احاطه امنيه عسكريه لاعضاء الكنيست
في كتله الليكود التي يتزعمها نتنياهو
الحاكمه في اسرائيل بعد ظهر هذا اليوم
ايضا في نفس السياق فواضح بان هذا ياتي
للتاثير على مستويين للتاثير على حزب الله
لبنان
وللتاجر تحديدا ان عامس هوشن مبعوث
الرئاسي الامريكي مكك بين بيروت وتل ابيب
وكانت مهمته الاساسيه هي محاوله التوصل
لتسويات في عدد من النقاط الحدوديه البريه
الخلافيه ال 13 ع على طول الحدود مع لبنان
على امل ان تقود مثل هذه التسويات الى نزع
فتيل انفجار محتمل من ناحيه وايضا وصول
وزير الخارجيه بلينكن مساء هذا اليوم الى
تل ابيب ومن ضمن اجندته ايضا العمل على
منع توسيع الحرب لتشمل منطقه الجبهه مع
لبنان او جبهات اخرى لذا
الحراك العسكري الميداني هدفه ايضا
التاثير على الحراك السياسي الدبلوماسي
واسرائيل مثلما تقول بانها تعمق ا حراك
دبلوماسي اسمح لي فقط يسعى للملم هذا
الصراع عدم خروجه عن السيطره واسرائيل
تفعل عكس ذلك بعد عمليات كهذه واغتيال
قائد ميداني الان في حزب ال هل تتخذ
اسرائيل في العاده احتياطات احترازيه بعد
عمليه كهذه لا سما وان هذه المره قد
تجاوزت قواعد للشباك مع حزب
الله هي هي الاجراءات التحوط الامنيه
العسكريه متواصله منذ بدايه الحرب وتصاعدت
في الايام الاخيره على طول الحدود اسرائيل
كان كانت قبل ايام قد عززت من منظومه
القبه الحديديه في مناطق عده في الجليلين
الاعلى والاسفل ومنطقه الجلام وعادت وعززت
من قواتها الموجوده على طول الحدود مع
لبنان وهي قوات كبيره جدا وسبق لقاده
الجيش وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان ان قالوا
بانهم استخدموا حتى الان فقط 10% من
سلاحهم الجوي في حربهم على غزه وان باقي
القوه كما قال جلنت في حينه
خراطيم الطائرات موجهه نحو لبنان نحو
الشمال وهذا مؤشر اخر على انهم على اهبه
الاستعداد للدخول في حرب واسعه تصريح
نتنياهو قبل قليل يشير الى انهم يحاولون
دغدغه مزاج الدبلوماسيين الذين ينشطون من
خلال القول بان اسرائيل معنيه بالتوصل الى
النتيجه التي تريدها بالادوات والوسائل
الدبلوماسيه السياسيه بمعنى ان ابعاد حزب
الله عن الحدود الى خلف الليطاني حسب ما
ردد بعض الوزراء الاسرائيليين وايضا اعاده
الامن الى المناطق الشماليه هذه المناطق
التي يقصدونها الشماليه فيها 21 بلده
وكبوت اسرائيلي متاخم للحدود تم افراغها
من ساكنيها هؤلاء جميعهم نزحوا الى داخل
اسرائيل وعدد كبير منها معطل ومشلول
بالكامل
وهم وهذا جزء ك 7 من اصل
125 نزحوا على الحدود في غلاف غزه وايضا
على الحدود مع لبنان اشكرك جزيل الشكر
وليد العمري مدير مكتبنا في رام الله